>> I FORGOT ABOUT THAT.
THAT WAS A NICE VISION ACTUALLY.
>> Sandra: THE DOW UP 900
POINTS.
UNPRECEDENTED MOVE IN ITALY AS
THE CORONAVIRUS CONTINUES TO
SPREAD.
THE PRIME MINISTER HAS PUT A
TOTAL LOCKDOWN FOR ALL 60
MILLION PEOPLE UNTIL NEXT MONTH.
ITALY HAS THE BIGGEST CLUSTER
OF CASES WITH MORE THAN 7300
INFECTED PATIENTS AT THIS TIME.
AMY KELLOGG IS LIVE IN FLORENCE.
>> THERE HAS BEEN ROLLING AND
REGIONAL RESTRICTIONS OVER THE
PAST FEW WEEKS.
THE PRIME MINISTER TOOK
ITALIANS BY SURPRISE LAST NIGHT
BY SAYING I HAVE A NEW DECREE
FOR THE WHOLE NATION AND THAT
CAN BE SUMMARIZED AS I WILL
STAY AT HOME.
NOW, IT IS NOT CLEAR HOW
STRINGENT THESE NEW RULES WILL
BE, HOW THEY WILL BE ENFORCED.
BUT A DOCUMENT, A PERMISSION
SLIP THAT NEEDS TO BE FILLED
OUT BY EVERY PERSON WHO CHOOSES
TO MOVE AROUND HAS BEEN
PUBLISHED.
IT HAS TO GO TO THE INTERIOR
MINISTRY AND BE APPROVED.
NOT JUST MOVEMENT ANYMORE INTO
AND OUT OF NORTHERN ITALY THAT
IS BEING RESTRICTED.
NOW THE ENTIRE COUNTRY OF LIGHT
IS ON LOCK DOWN.
>> THERE WILL NO LONGER BE A
RED ZONE OR ZONE 1 AND 2.
THERE WILL BE ITALY.
THAT’S A PROTECTED ZONE
>> PEOPLE BECAME VERY PANICKED
LAST NIGHT AFTER HEARING ABOUT
THIS HAVING ENOUGH PROVISIONS.
LINES OUTSIDE SUPERMARKETS
WHERE THEY’RE LETTING PEOPLE IN
IN SMALL NUMBERS AND ENFORCING
THE THREE-FOOT DISTANCE RULE.
THE SITUATION OUTSIDE.
PRISONS REMAIN TENSE WITH
POLICE WORRIED ABOUT RIOTS
AFTER IT BROKE OUT AFTER
VISITATIONS AND RESTRICTIONS
WERE ANNOUNCED.
THAT REMAINS CALM THIS MORNING.
VERY TENSE.
AGAIN IT IS NOT CLEAR EXACTLY
HOW THIS IS GOING TO WORK OUT.
I SNUCK OUT TO GET A FEW
PROVISIONS THIS MORNING AND
THERE ARE HOLES AND
INCONSISTENCIES IN HOW IT IS
ALL WORKING.
BASICALLY THE IDEA IS IN ORDER
TO LIMIT THE SPREAD OF CASES
HERE WHAT THE GOVERNMENT IS
TRYING ITS BEST TO DO IS LIMIT
CONTACT BETWEEN PEOPLE.
SO NOBODY IS KIND OF EXPANDING